Minnesota Attorney General Keith Allison
increases the charges against George
Floyd's alleged killer leftists prepare
to blame racism for a covet 19 uptick
and Drew Brees comes under fire for
defending the American flag i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why have you not obtained a
VPN yet go to expressive VPN comm slash
ban that's expressvpn comm / ban okay so
I think what we are watching in
increasing numbers is people converting
to the religion of woken us and the
religion of woken us is really exciting
stuff the religion of openness has all
the other stuff that religions have it
has catechisms things that you're just
supposed to listen and repeat you may
not understand them but if you don't
repeat them this means you're bad and
you have sinned it's got a nearly
impenetrable code that the code is
constantly changing and it's constantly
moving you have no idea what the
standard is from day to day but that
code is brought to you by a priestly
caste of really intelligent and woke
people who will be able to absolve you
of sin so long as you listen to
everything they say there is an
intermediary between you and woken us
the intermediary is fairly obvious right
it is all the members of the New York
Times editorial board it is all the
people who tweet angrily on Twitter it
is your late-night host but even they
have intermediaries they have to call in
some of their black friends we saw on
all the late-night TV shows last night
in order to interpret blackness for them
so that they can absolve themselves of
their own white privilege it's got
sacrificial rites right people who are
bad who do not who do not now the proper
catechism are immediately destroyed and
there's no forgiveness and there's no
forgiveness and it's got public
atonement rituals where you're supposed
to come out and make apologies for
absolutely anodyne things if you if you
do not repeat things loud enough or long
enough then you are considered bad the
the religion of woken as' suggests a
bunch of conflicting things and the only
way to avoid the conflict is to just
listen and repeat listen and believe
right that's the basic idea here so we
have heard over the past 48 hours a few
things yes I would say several years but
really exacerbated in the last 48 hours
we have heard that speech is violence so
if I say something you don't like
I have enacted violence upon you I used
to hear this when I would speak at
college campuses people were literally
chanting speeches violence when I spoke
at UC Berkeley also silence is violence
so if you don't speak that's a form of
violence so if you do speak and we don't
like it that's violence if you don't
speak that is also a form of violence so
America has now adopted
tap dancing apparently as its new
solution or my memory I mean that data
peak its violence we don't speak it's
violence so we have to find
some other form of communication the
religious nature of woken us is
incredible it is a substitute for
religion people are filling a god-shaped
hole in their hearts with performative
virtue signaling and what the virtuous
signaling is really designed to do in
the end is to separate is to separate
you off from the non-believers it really
isn't designed to actually be virtuous
it is not that you're doing anything
virtuous when you kneel as a white
person in front of a black protester and
then suggest that America is endemically
racist that is not you being a virtuous
person that is you actively separating
yourself off from people who will not do
that it is you suggesting because you're
not actually taking on the sin what
you're actually doing is saying I am not
responsible for the sins of the past I
am NOT responsible for any of the bad
things going on in society please leave
me alone all those other white folks who
are not doing this those are the people
who are responsible so it's it's amazing
to watch this blossom and and become the
state religion of the United States it's
obviously the religion in Europe you
seen tens of thousands of people in
Europe marching about police brutality
in the United States which is fairly
interesting considering that over in
Europe they have a significant problem
with for example massive anti-semitism
that has led to the mass exodus of Jews
from Europe but haven't seen a lot of
marches about that in your Hong Kong was
recently completely taken over by the
Chinese government and it's millions of
citizens subjected to the jackboot of
the Chinese government no protests about
that but when it comes to America being
bad that's something we can all agree on
because America as the leader of Western
civilization that really is the new
religion the new religion is that the
first article of faith is that America
is bad was bad will be bad was rooted in
corruption and evil and therefore if we
can all march together about that we can
separate ourselves off from the stench
of evil Western civilization and we can
rip again none of this is to argue that
marching against police brutality is
that marching against police brutality
is fine we all agree on that but that is
not the program that is being
promulgated by members of the media it
is not the program that is being
promulgated by many of the protesters I
would say most of the protesters they're
not out there marching about police
brutality purely they're out there
marching with the assumption that
America is systemically an endemic ly
racist when that American law
enforcement is systemically an endemic
ly racist if this were just about police
brutality there wouldn't be any kneeling
and if this were just about police
brutality there wouldn't be any talk
about how America has deep on
extirpated sin that everyone in america
is responsible for unless you do all
these things that the world want you to
do if this were just about police
brutality we'd all agree as I pointed
out yesterday we all agree on certain
fundamental propositions proposition
number one police brutality is evil
praten number two we all agree riding
and mooning is evil number three well
agree individual instances of racism
right actual instances of racism are
evil right we're all in agreement on
that but that's how what these marches
are about but these marches have become
about is a broader agenda which is
basically suggesting that America at
root root and branch is very very very
bad and the media have taken that to the
logical extreme by suggesting that
rioting and looting are merely an
extension of the protest now again do I
think all the protesters believe there's
no but I think that the messaging that
is being put forth including the
kneeling me the obvious attempt to mimic
the message those put forth by Colin
Kaepernick right that is clearly the
message that is now being put forth by
many of the protesters and that I object
to because if you can split the messages
I'm all for one I'm not for the other
all against police brutality all against
racism all against the against the the
use of of policing in the wrong ways all
of that agreed against riding all of all
that agreed but if the idea here and as
you'll see this is the idea if the idea
is that if you don't greenlight rioting
and looting that if you say the rioting
looting should be stopped if you believe
that America is actually an incredible
wonderful place in the story of America
is a story of tremendous founding
principles and uh Nan unchallenged good
philosophy that was that was failed by
Americans for centuries but the story of
America is the perfection of our
behavior in accordance with original
ideal so the story of America is America
getting better in accordance with
founding ideals if you believe that's
the case then you are to be thrown out
and as you'll see this is actually what
is happening to people right if you say
that America is a good place and the
flag is good you will now be called out
as not being sufficiently woke and you
will be called races so we're gonna get
to all of that in just one second first
I have to bring you some updates on the
George Floyd actual criminal case and
it's imperative that people understand
the facts of the George Floyd criminal
case because you might need to know
what's going to happen next and we'll
get to that in just one second first
have you noticed there might be a little
bit of economic uncertainty I know about
you I've been I've been noticing a
little bit of economic uncertainty you
know like the 40 million people who are
unemployed the fact that we are blowing
out the spending
at a faster rate and any time in human
history in human history
we've spent seven trillion dollars in
the last three months long and there
will be another round of massive
government spending well this is gonna
have consequences things like raise
taxes possible inflation slow economic
recovery all of this is disastrous but
one thing that you should do in order to
bet against volatility and make sure
that you are basically insured against
the ups and downs of the markets and
government intervention ISM you might
want to diversify into precious metals
at least a little bit go talk to my
friends right now over at Birch gold if
you haven't reached out to Birch gold to
diversify part of your eligible IRA or
401k into a precious metals IRA don't
wait for the bottom to fall out again
instead text Ben to 47 47 47 and when
you purchase on or before July 31st
you'll get a free signed copy of my book
the right side of history Birch gold
we'll go to work for you at making super
simple text Ben - 47 47 47 and at least
request a free information can untie
versifying it's called ask all your
questions get all your answers no
obligation Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless 5-star reviews a plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau I know
them I trust them text Ben - 47 47 47
during the month of June or July when
you open an IRA in precious metals you
do get a signed copy of my book the
right side of history for free now make
sure that you I should want to do it
don't just do it for the book make sure
that it makes sense for you financially
the folks at Birch gold can help answer
your questions on this text Ben - 47 47
47 text my name Ben - 47 47 47 okay so
let's go to the the actual facts of the
George Floyd prosecution because it
seems to me that the Attorney General of
Minnesota is is now doing something that
is actually legally dangerous if you
would like to see the officer in this
case go to jail then you need to charge
him with the crime that he committed and
then you need to convict him of that
crime one of the great great dangers
that we have seen in other cases is
overcharging are people putting forth a
charge that they cannot fulfill so for
example if there had been an attempt to
charge George Zimmerman with
manslaughter as opposed to murder
there's a better case that he's probably
in jail right now if however you are
talking about if you're talking about
charging somebody with second-degree or
first degree murder when they're
obviously guilty of manslaughter or
assault then you can easily see somebody
acquitted on a higher charge now people
don't seem to understand how this works
a charge is not your indicator of how
seriously you take a crime and that that
is not how charging works if you say
second-degree murder as opposed to
third-degree murder that's not because
you're taking the crime more seriously
or if you say third-degree murder as
opposed to second-degree murder that's
not because you're taking the crime less
seriously crimes have definitions and so
what we have seen in the media and in
from art and from many of the people
online is that they think that because
Attorney General keith Ellison upgraded
charges against the former Minneapolis
police officer who knelt on George
Floyd's neck from third-degree murder to
second-degree murder that this is
somehow a an indicator that Minneapolis
is that Minnesota is taking this thing
more seriously that's that's really not
how criminal law is supposed to work nor
should any of these decisions be driven
by people outside the justice system
making decisions about how to elevate
charges based on public outrage that's
that's a fool's errand
it's stupid for a variety of reasons one
it's not equal justice under law but two
it is really really stupid to change
your charges to something you can't
prove because of public pressure
so yesterday Keith Ellison who by the
way it was an awful congressperson awful
congressperson I mean openly
anti-semitic in bookstores holding up
pictures of books bet with an Tifa and
like really a bad Congress person so
keith Ellison yesterday he made this
announcement he said that George Floyd
matter which of course everyone agrees
about considering that everyone agrees
about it to the Floyd family to our
beloved community and to everyone that
is watching I say George Floyd mattered
he was loved his family was important
his life had value and we will seek
justice for him and for you and we will
find it the very fact that we have filed
these charges means that we believe in
them but what I do not believe is that
one successful prosecution can rectify
the hurt and loss that so many people
feel right so so now we are going to
continue to to perpetuate the narrative
that even if the justice system works
the justice system is not working right
now that's what Ellison is saying at the
very end that even if we convict this
guy then that has not alleviated the
situation in any real way Magic Johnson
is a good indicator of the sort of
reaction that the elevation of the
charges earned online so Magic Johnson
obviously the former NBA star and now
part owner of the of the LA Lakers he's
I'm so thrilled the menace
Attorney General Keith Ellison amended
the police officer who killed George
Floyd's charge to second degree from
third degree and have then announced the
other three Minneapolis officers have
been charged with aiding and abetting
George Floyd's murder I'm wondering what
his legal take is on that because like
he says the work does not stop here they
must be sentenced we also need to
continue to call for a change without
policymakers if you believe that
agitation gets charged is elevated
that's really not a good thing you don't
want political agitation elevating
charges you want people charged with the
crimes they can commit and that is a bad
thing and everyone left right and center
should agree that is a bad thing if you
can just add jeté said someone is
charged with a with a crime with a
higher penalty that's not how the
justice system is supposed to work but
the real question is whether they are
being charged with the correct crime
because there are and the reason I'm
talking about this is because if you're
a defense lawyer and you look at the
case against Eric shavon it is not
impossible that Eric shavon gets off on
this case it is not impossible that he's
acquitted in fact I would say that
there's at least a 35 percent
possibility that he's acquitted on these
charges and the reason I say that is
because of two specific elements one is
that the charges themselves might be
overcharged so when you look at what the
what the charges suggest the difference
is between second and third degree
murder for example second-degree murder
is typically described as you have to
have intended to have done it right
intent is a key element of the case well
it's really not clear from the video
that shavon intended to kill him it
looks more like malicious and wanton
destruction right I mean it looks more
like third degree third degree is
malicious is basically reckless
disregard right that you did something
that could kill somebody and didn't care
you just did it anyway right that's what
that video looks like does it look like
shavon was actively attempting to kill
George Floyd second-degree sort of
requires that now they're their various
sort of interpretations of these charges
there's a good piece over at Heritage
Foundation from a legal expert they're
saying the second-degree actually is the
appropriate charge we'll get to that in
a second but according to CNN under
Minnesota law third degree murder is to
find his causing death of a person by
perpetrating an act eminently dangerous
to others and in Vinson a depraved mind
with threat without regard for life and
without intent skill which is what this
looks like but they just elevated it
from third degree to second degree
according to CNN legal
analyst Laura coats a former US District
Attorney for the District of Columbia
she is she is saying that now the the
the the other charges would require that
a person plans and willingly carries out
a killing or has intention to kill in
the spur of the moment now the other
possibility is second degree murder is
felony murder is that you're committing
a felony and in the process of the
felony you kill somebody so you're
robbing a store and your gun
accidentally goes off and kills somebody
that's felony murder you'd have to claim
that shavon was committing a felony
which I guess you could call this felony
assault maybe and that's the theory of
the case perhaps but it's a risky charge
it depends under which charges they are
moving if they're going to claim that he
had intent to kill show that Chavan had
intent to kill Floyd you could certainly
see a jury saying well it looks more
like he accidentally killed him after
doing a very very bad terrible brutal
thing and so he's not actually guilty of
second-degree murder he might be guilty
of manslaughter for example voluntary
manslaughter but you could see a jury
doing that and this has happened in
other cases overcharging leads to
acquittals so that is problem number one
with the case
hey then there is the then there is the
problem of the other people who are
being charged so they're charging the
three other officers with aiding and
abetting the statute that that charge is
aiding and abetting is you are
criminally liable for a crime committed
by another if a person intentionally
aids advises hires counsels or conspires
with or otherwise procures the other to
commit the crime so usually that means
like you hired somebody or you were
riding in the same car with somebody and
you decided to commit the crime together
you standing by and not doing anything
not quite as clear under Minnesota law
right according to legal expert over at
the at the daily signal the three other
officers mere presence at the scene or
their inaction alone would not be
sufficient for aiding and abetting
instead they would have had to play a
knowing role in shaolin's crime now it's
possible they get convicted if they
quote-unquote did nothing to prevent the
offenses committed or the brutal or the
brutal activity because if you must have
known of the activity and the and made
no effort to stop it then that makes the
crime possible you could theoretically
make that case but it's gonna be hard to
argue aiding and abetting when the
officers are just standing there meaning
where were they complicit in the in the
act that that's a hard legal line to
draw so again that's not making the case
that they shouldn't be convicted but it
is
making the case that you actually want
to look at these facts because if you
think things are bad right now wait
until a jury acquits the three other
officers on charges of aiding and
abetting because the legal because legal
definition ain't all that clear or if
they're Excel then gets off because
Ellison overcharged right that that
could be a real disaster it's why you
have to be very specific as a prosecutor
and exactly what you are doing also if
you're the defense lawyer you have you
have a fairly decent case that this is
not second-degree murder specifically
because there are two separate autopsies
now again there are certain things you
could certainly charge her and you could
you could certainly convict for right
felony assault would be an obvious one
right this is obviously an assault it's
out actually it's a battery right he's
committing battery on George Floyd right
so there are certain things he should go
to jail I mean this is none of this is
to doubt that shavon did something
brutal and should go to jail the
question is you need to prepare the
American public for the facts of the
case because otherwise what you end up
with is this miasmatic sense in the
atmosphere the chaplains gonna go to
jail for life and then Ellison over
charges or the defense puts on a fairly
solid case and he gets off and then it's
the American justice system is racist
again and that's that's the way this
goes we saw this with Michael Brown for
example in a second I'm going to explain
why the various autopsy reports also
could be used in defense of the officer
again people need to know this this is
not me making a defense of the officers
activity at all you officer should go to
jail the question is under what
circumstances in for what crime because
again if you overcharged you end up with
an acquittal and things are gonna be a
lot worse a year from now if there's an
acquittal in this case we're gonna get
some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that now
is a terrible time to go to the post
office like an awful time to go to the
post office in fact you may not even be
able to go to the post office right now
do you really want to schlep packages
over the post office and wait in line
and brave the wilds of your major city
right now probably not probably what you
would like to do is instead send all
your mail from home and this is why you
should be using stamps calm with
stamps.com you can print postage on the
man and skip the lines and crowds at the
post office plus you can actually save
some money with discounts you can't even
get at the post office as if that wasn't
enough stamps calm also offers UPS
services with discounts up to 62 percent
no UPS residential surcharges here at
Dailey why are we vie we've been using
stamps calm since 2017 we will not waste
our time simply use your computer you
can
it's official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just leave it for your
mail carrier schedule a free package
pick up or drop it in the mailbox no
human contact required it is indeed that
simply you can save time you can save
money we do here at daily wear right now
my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage ands digital scale no long term
commitment just head on over to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro that
stamps calm and use Shapiro at the very
top of the homepage and you will get
those special deals before a trial plus
free postage and digital scale in the
long term commitment which is a
fantastic fantastic deal okay so the the
autopsy's that came back in the George
Floyd case are conflicting so there is
the official autopsy that was done by
the government medical examiner and it's
important here that that we note that
there are only a few classifications on
government documents when it comes to
death certificates and autopsies so
there's accident there's natural death
and there's homicide right there they're
really only a few different categories
that you can put down a homicide does
not mean that somebody was murdered or
that somebody was killed all it means
that somebody committed an act that
ended in death right so that doesn't
mean that it was the proximate cause of
the death it means that it was not
natural you didn't die in bed it wasn't
an accident you didn't get hit by a car
right it wasn't a and it wasn't a and it
wasn't you know a lightning strike or
something right so so the the the mere
classification of homicide does not mean
that a murder took place so people you
need to understand how the process works
if you understand what exactly these
documents are saying so the original
charging document against the against
Chavan said no physical findings that
support a diagnosis of traumatic
asphyxia or strangulation instead it was
a combination of force and health
problems contributing to the death in
other words according to police report
by the way George Floyd was saying I
can't breathe before the neck before the
knee was put on his neck if you are the
lawyer you're going to say Shelvin did
something wrong here he committed an
assault but he didn't kill him you
didn't mean to kill him he didn't kill
him he died because he had he had
fentanyl in his system he because he had
some sort of pre-existing condition and
even according to the medical examiner
there was no traumatic asphyxia under
strangulation meaning he wasn't crushing
his windpipe right
he may have exacerbated in underlying
health situations like Eric garner in
New York again but he didn't actually so
that's what the defense is going to say
now the independent autopsy says that
George Floyd's death was homicide caused
by asphyxia due to neck and back
compression that led to lack of blood
flow to flow to the brain so that is a
different autopsy report that's the one
that's being done by the family so that
is going to be the area in which the
defense focuses the reason I'm bringing
this all up is because it's very
important to understand the facts of the
case so that you charge correctly and so
that we understand what is going to
happen once this gets into a courtroom
because people don't pay attention to
any of the details and then they are
shocked when things do not go the way
they want them to go we saw this with
Michael Brown the case of Michael Brown
in Ferguson Missouri the original case
as reported by the media was Michael
Brown was shot in the back with his
hands up and it turned out that none of
the facts supported any element of that
story and then the officer was not in
fact indicted by a grand jury and people
went nuts because the assumption had
been from the original media coverage
that this was going to turn into that
sort of case he saw the same thing with
Trayvon Martin and George Zimmerman the
original story told by the media was
that Trayvon Martin had been stalked and
then shot down in cold blood by George
Zimmerman and as it turns out the story
was different and so it looked like an
overcharged by the prosecutors and he
was acquitted and that was what happened
so focus it like the media are being
irresponsible if they don't tell you all
the facts so that you can urge the
prosecutors to actually charge correctly
and put this guy in jail for the thing
he did not for a thing that cannot be
that he cannot be proved to have done if
you want him in jail
you need the prosecutors to do the right
thing not to overcharge on the basis of
people being mad on Twitter and thinking
that you are more virtuous for
overcharging than you would be for
actually appropriately charging in this
case yeah that this is this is a case
for putting the person in jail not a
case against putting the person and John
ok so meanwhile that that's all the the
underlying facts because remember George
Floyd is the the victim here I mean
George Floyd was at the center of this
case I know that's all been forgotten
and I know that everything is becoming
slogan right now but it seems to me that
if you care about George Floyd and
justice for his family you should want
the officer to go to jail and it seems
like the facts of the case are relevant
to that particular inquiry okay in a
second we're gonna get to the narrative
because the narrative has now become
utterly stupid utterly religious in
nature the religion of woken us has
taken over in every way we'll get to
that in just one second first
everything going on right now a lot of
people asking if you can't even buy life
insurance considering all of the
insanity surrounding covet considering
the rioting and the looting can even buy
life insurance well the answer is yes I
mean you can still buy life insurance
the best way to do it and do it easily
is over at policy genius.com as an
insurance marketplace policy genius is
in contact with the life insurance
companies on their platform every day
they're keeping track of all the changes
in the market so you don't have to which
means they can get you covered quickly
and for the best price here's how it
works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you could say 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free so
if you had any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to take care of everything as a
responsible human being you should take
care of the people who rely on you even
in case god forbid something happens to
you you should have life insurance you
should also have disability in auto
insurance and all the insurance you need
head on over to policy genius.com right
now policy genius will find you the best
rate and handle the process completely
they'll get you and your family
protected hopefully give you one less
thing to worry about these days policy
genius.com go check them out right now
ok so the religion of wellness has now
taken over as I said before and I will
say again virtually everybody agrees on
certain basic propositions racism bad
police brutality bad rioting and looting
bad but we have now reached the point
where a huge swath of Americans are
arguing for something different about
which there should be and is widespread
disagreement one is the proposition that
America is endemically racist and evil
that black people are under existential
threat in the United States from police
and from white Americans and the
proposition that racism can really be
blamed for everything now there are a
couple of different types of
propositions they are all explanatory
one is conspiracy theories conspiracy
theories are completely explanatory they
are all explanatory and second is the
end the end the second one is religion
and when it comes to conspiracy theory
everything can be explained by
malevolent people behind the scenes
pulling the strings right this is the
these sort of anti-semitic conspiracy
theories or by the way the idea of
institutional racism that a bunch of
white people are sitting behind the
scenes and
liberally attempting to harm black
people if you're making that argument
you're an idiot
that's the there there's there is not
some some cadre of white people out
there or like how do we keep black
people down today that does not exist
that is not a thing if there are people
who think that way there they're living
in a bunker or somewhere in Idaho right
I mean that that's that is that it ends
like four of them so that's not real
okay the other one is is religion
religion suggests that there is an
all-encompassing logic to the universe
and it is provided by God the Creator
who stands behind the logic of the
universe the religion of wolken is is a
religion it suggests that there is a
creator of America a creator of Western
civilization that Creator is not God
that crater is not human beings with
actual agency that creator is racism
racism is malevolent God in the religion
of wellness and it is up to you to fight
that malevolent God because everything
can be explained by racism literally all
things and if you think it can't be
explained by racism it's because you're
not going high-level enough so take for
example there's a tweet yesterday and it
is just a perfect example of this
religion from Mark Levine and Mark
Levine writes let's meet this guy is the
chair of New York City Council Health
Committee remember one second ago he was
saying that you were murdering
grandmother if you went outside without
a mask now he says let's be clear about
something if there is a spike in
coronavirus cases in the next two weeks
don't blame the protesters blame racism
ah racism the all-purpose god of the
gaps for the left right hence explain
different differentials you can't
explain inequalities you're you're
unwilling to say the behavior might be
an actual factor in unequal outcomes
well then that's because because racism
because racism racism is the God of the
gaps and let's say they even say that
let's say that for example you suggest
that hey wait a second the protesters
they might have higher levels of Kobe 19
because they're out there infecting each
other and that's I thought that's bad
right I mean I thought we opposed that
didn't we until like five seconds ago
well here's the thing you can't blame
the protesters because the protesters
are processing racism so if you just
remove one level then racism is still to
blame and this is like the argument that
suggests oh by the way you might notice
that police officers are having tons and
tons of law enforcement encounters with
black people and maybe that is the
reason for elevated
numbers of bad incidents involving
police and black people if you're
talking about disproportionate numbers
of black people being arrested maybe
it's not that the police officers are
just rounding up black folks maybe it's
that black people are statistically
committing more crimes on average then
white people are that 13% of that 13% of
the American population is black but
something like forty to fifty percent of
all murders in the United States are
committed by black men and therefore the
police are having more encounters with
black homicide suspects than they are
with white homicide suspects as a
percentage of the population well then
so that would be an answer to why the
police are having these encounters with
black people that does not implicate
racism so then if you are a true
religious woke person what you say is no
no it's still racism it's still racism
because you see the institution of the
police itself was racist and was
instituted as a racist institution and
not only that here at the the difference
in human behavior today between the
black man who murders somebody and the
white man who murders somebody is
attributable to historic racism so the
reason that you have these differentials
in the first place is because of slavery
and Jim Crow so you can always just
remove one level and then you get to
racism as the bottom line rationale for
everything it's the all important factor
in everything it's the explanatory
factor and everything that's a religious
perspective because when you ask people
to nail down exactly how that works it's
nearly impossible but if you refuse to
accept that that is the case then you
are a heretic and you must be outed and
you must be Elstad and that is how you
end up blaming racism for kovat 19 up
ticks at the rallies with thousands of
people protesting when it is perfectly
obvious why you're going to see an
uptick if you do see an uptick and it's
because you have thousands of people
breathing all over each other and the
virus doesn't care why you're out there
protesting okay so this this has become
a religion and you can see the religious
aspects of it in the human behavior
surrounding it the virtue signaling is
not about actual virtue it is about the
idea that you are fighting against the
heretics you are fighting against the
barbarians the gates who doubt the story
so best example ever this this example
from Bethesda Maryland which is a rich
white suburb in Maryland I don't see any
of these people sending their kids
busing their kids into inner cities into
impoverished schools with heavy minority
populations out of solidarity but what
they are will
to do is sit on the ground and then
listen and repeat this is just a
religious ceremony it's a religious
right white people are supposed to are
supposed to accept the sins of their
forefathers upon them but that's not
really what they're doing let's be real
about this what they're actually doing
is they're now able to go around and say
to their friends well I accept white
privilege but you don't you don't and
thus you are damned to the reality is
that I accepted the sim but I don't
really accept this in because the sins
not on me man i extirpated the sin I I
did my atonement I did my public
atonement ritual I sacrificed my goat
you didn't sacrifice your goat
therefore you're the one who really
carries the communal sin upon you
because you are the one continuing to
perpetuate racism by not doing this
random symbolic act today that's a
religious tank here was the religious
take yesterday in Bethesda Maryland
about racism anti blackness or violence
I would use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
and to everything in my powers I speak
my community I will love my black
neighbors the same as my white ones I
mean this is it's a public atonement
ritual that's what it is and by the way
when they take I will educate everybody
no you won't what you will do is you
will repeat what this person says to you
to somebody else and then you will claim
that you have educated somebody you will
proselytize on behalf of people who
quote unquote know better right that
that's what's going on here there's a
reason why white liberals are the people
who are most likely to defend looting
all right there's a poll out today
showing that white college-educated
liberals are the people most likely to
defend looting because most Americans
don't buy into this crap but if you are
a deep devotee of the religion of
intersectionality if you're a deep
devotee of the idea that white privilege
decides everything in America and you
are going to defend looting because you
just don't understand the looters don't
you see you don't understand their lived
experience and until you understand
their lived experience you can't fight
back again
racism is to blame for the lewodan just
remove it one level remember it's not
the people making the decision to steal
that pair of shoes from footlocker
supposedly a memory of George Floyd or
some such nonsense that the Floyd family
actively actively says is bad no it's
that racism at a higher level drove
people into poverty and drove them into
despair and drove them into stealing a
pair of shoes from the Nike store
even if Nike puts out an ad talking
about a bad racism is right this is the
religion and the religion must be
listened to at all times I'll get two
more examples of this because it's
astonishing I mean it has gone to two
utterly extraordinary lengths Americans
should not buy into this it it destroys
the possibility of unity because for the
1 million and two hundred thousand and
seventy third time we all have unity on
racism is bad
we all have unity on police brutality is
bad but that's not what the religion
says the religion must have outcast the
religion must have heretics and the
religion makes claims that are
significantly beyond racism is bad - you
are a racist if you don't do random from
performative thing I tell you to do
today if you do not read these chicken
entrails the way I tell you today you
are bad and you are an enemy of the
religion and you must be made to repent
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk
about the fact that right now probably
not a great time to go to the local
autozone probably you should just shop
for that auto part online also when you
go to the local autozone you're spending
too much money
Rock Auto calm it's so much easier than
walking into a store and then somebody
asking you very specific questions about
your car that you don't actually have on
you and they give you generic auto part
or they tell you they have to order it
anyway just use the interwebs
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why spend up to
twice as much for the same part and in
many cases that's exactly what you're
doing if you go to the auto parts store
as opposed to going to rockauto.com
prices at rockauto.com
are always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
part rockauto.com check them out right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck right shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you have amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need Rock auto comm again
that is Rock Auto calm their catalog is
unique it is remarkably easy to navigate
go check out rockauto.com right now
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box that helps them that helps
us please check them out right now Rock
Auto calm already in a second we're
gonna get to some in just pure proof
that this has now become basically a
religious a religious conflict a
religious conflict in which the he woke
are not actually proposing anything that
remotely resembles reality it's not
about practical proposals it's not about
things that we can either agree or
disagree about is about generalized
propositions manifested in bizarre acts
generalized propositions like America is
bad manifested in bizarre acts like
kneeling before kneeling before
protesters and then if you don't do that
then it's because you're bad we're gonna
get to that in just one second first
listen up the double tumbler is bad but
only available for our most exclusive
membership tier all access the
all-access membership here is our
premier level of membership all access
members get to participate in all access
live it's our brand-new interactive
programming featuring one of the daily
warehouses we hang out with you each
night tonight I'm on the hook again all
access members get to join us for
real-time Q&A discussions available on
both the website and the daily wire app
also again you get the two magical
leftist tiers tumblr they're reproducing
in real time the tumblers are
overflowing with tears finally all
access members also get the benefits of
our Mount other membership tiers that
includes the add free website experience
access to our live broadcasts and show
library access to the shows mailbags the
full three hours of the ben shapiro show
along with dedicated editorials from moi
so head on over to daily wire comm slash
subscribe join all access get 15% off
with coupon code Shapiro right now that
Stanley wire comm slash subscribe also
now would be a great time for you to go
out and pre-purchase I don't mean to
pitch my book on the back of the horror
show that we are seeing across the
United States right now but it is
extraordinarily relevant I'll admit when
I wrote this book I wrote this book back
in December January when I wrote this
book and then kovat hit I thought maybe
it's not so relevant um I was wrong the
book is called how to destroy America in
three easy steps the basic premise of
the book is that there is a group of
people I call them disintegration
astaire interested in the disintegration
of the American Union and they are
trying to destroy America's philosophy
culture and history our shared
philosophy of rights under the
Constitution and Declaration of
Independence our institutions themselves
our culture of rights the idea that free
speech matters as we will see the New
York Times no longer believes us and
will end and our shared history the
notion that we share history even if our
history has victimization of some groups
by other groups the glory of our history
is that that victimization ended and the
bravery of those victimized groups
that's all part of our shared history a
Martin Luther King jr. is part of my
history too Jim Crow is part of my
history too yes Emma white because I'm
an American
hey it's part of your history too so are
the evils the evils are part of your
history - because we're all Americans my
book how to destroy America in three
easy steps is about the destruction of
any semblance of unity in the country on
the back of a separate narrative that
suggests that American philosophy is a
true evil then American history is at
root corrupt and that American America's
culture of rights is at root and it's in
excuse for exploitation go check out my
book it's coming out July 21st there is
an audiobook version of it you can get
that right you can pre-order it right
now how do destroy America in three easy
steps go check it out right now you're
listening so the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so the religion of woke miss
it has its priests and it has its
devotees and it has its and it has its
proselytizers as well so the the the
sort of hierarchy in terms of the
priestly case are people like the people
over at the new york times so the people
over at the new york times there is a
piece written by the sitting senator tom
cotton from Arkansas who was a member of
the military and he wrote a piece called
sending the troops and was about the use
of the military to stop rioting and
looting which by the way happened in
1992 it has happened repeatedly in
American history if you require the
National Guard or he required the
military in order to stop writing and
looting there was plenty of legal
precedent for this the President does
have the power under the insurrection
act to do this it has been invoked
before the idea it's not been invoked
since 1807 is a lot okay so this thing
runs okay in the New York Times and New
York Times staffers then start using all
of the tactics they learned at Wellesley
in order to stop this tactic number one
is this thing if you've ever been at a
college press it's amazing I mean this
is all religious it's so religious the
SS a religious person I can identify the
symbols of religion when they are used
if you've ever been on a college campus
there's the thing that people do where
if a speaker says something you're not
supposed to clap because it might
traumatize somebody they do this right
that's their thing they snap to
symbolize agreement and also at their
protests as you saw in that in that
protest from Bethesda somebody will
repeat a slogan or a very very Wong sort
of in Qom iam and then you are supposed
to repeat it word for word say I pledge
to do X Y & Z I pledge to do x y&z in
support of the environment in support of
the environment and transgender lobsters
and transgender lobsters right that's
how it goes on college campuses so the
staffers at the New York Times are doing
this now
so Tom cotton has his op-ed printed and
this results in Taylor Lorenz a reporter
from the New York Times writing running
this puts black New York Times staff in
danger in danger rioting and looting is
not dangerous if you put an op-ed about
how you might need the police to put in
the military to put down riots and
looters you're putting black New York
Times staffers in danger why are you out
looting tonight Jers Lee what does that
put you how does that put you in danger
first of all to an op-ed it is not an
act of Congress second of all
if it were an act of Congress are you
rioting and looting tonight Taylor
Lorenz hey and then there was Katie
Weaver another your time staffer running
this put blacks running this puts black
in your time staff in danger
JC Fortin another New York time staffer
running this puts black New York time
staff in danger right they're doing the
exact well Leslie thing they're all
repeating the same things snapping all
right all of this to stop in the New
York Times from running a dissenting
op-ed I mean that this is this is absurd
it's absurd and then the New York Times
runs a separate piece about resistance
at the New York Times to the New York
Times editorial board so the New York
Times editorial board is not woke enough
because they ran a piece which by the
way the proposition that if we have to
use the military to put down the rioting
and looting that we should that is a
proposition that by polling data is
supported by somewhere between six and
seven in Americans out of ten it is a
vast majority proposition most Americans
agree why ever you have to do is we can
go back to work and so that we can you
know not be locked in our homes at 9:00
p.m. or for 1 p.m. in Beverly Hills
every day maybe maybe that maybe that's
worth it so the New York Times has now
run a full piece about the New York
Times The New York Times priesthood the
the intersectional priesthood dictating
religious terms to the New York Times
editorial board the most woke well is
Lee graduates who have used to see
everybody thought I didn't think this
because I've spent too much time on
college campuses to think this there's a
whole group people cancel culture
doesn't exist who cares about save
spaces and microaggressions once they
get out in the real world they're gonna
see this stuff doesn't work what if they
get out in the real world and then they
impose that system on everybody else
what if it turns out that what starts on
college campuses does not end on college
campuses it just started there if that's
what you're seeing at the New York Times
today according to the New York Times
and this would be mark tracey reporting
senators sending the troops op-ed in The
Times drawers online ire staff members
at the newspaper including a Pulitzer
winner denounced an opinion essay by Tom
cotton Republican of Arkansas calling
for a military response to protests The
Times has reported on the debate within
the administration over whether or not
to follow cotton suggestion but now you
have a bunch of members of the New York
Times or are criticizing the New York
Times op-ed board by the way you know
what I would do if staffers at my at my
new I run publication if my staffers
went online and started ripping me for
running in op-ed and we run a variety of
op
from the right many of them disagree
with each other if people went online
and they started suggesting that I'm
putting lives in danger
number one it should quit if you think
they are if you think that your
publication is putting lives in danger
or doing something so deeply immoral you
cannot work there
you should leave you should by the way I
did it back in 2016 I actually did I
left a publication over disagreements
with the way they were treating their
own reporter so I'm speaking from
experience here any of these New York
Times reporters can go up there cush job
with the cush salary anytime that but
they're not going to write they're gonna
virtue signal so instead you get a
variety of members of the newspaper
staff criticizing this so James Bennett
the editorial page editor was forced to
issue a statement times opinion owes it
to our readers to show them counter
arguments particularly those made by
people in a position to set policy we
understand that many readers find
senator Cotton's argument painful even
dangerous we believe that is one reason
it requires public scrutiny and debate
but this is bad bad bad bad bad bad
dozens of set of time staff members
tweeted the same sentence because Nicola
Hannah Jones correspondent for the New
York Times magazine who want to peel it
surprise for a garbage essay in which he
completely botched the history and she
continues to botch the history a person
who said literally yesterday that
rioting and looting is not actually
violence
did you know rioting and looting isn't
violence speech is violence quote I'll
probably get in trouble for this but to
not say something would be immoral as a
black woman as a journalist as an
American I am deeply ashamed that we ran
this well why you tossing some some
crappy history and some over art writing
they'll probably be fine with it
I mean then you want to peel it sir
maybe the news guild of New York a union
that represents many times journalists
said in a statement on Wednesday that
the op-ed quote promotes hate promotes
hate they said this is a particularly
vulnerable moment in American history
Cotton's op-ed pours gasoline on the
fire media organizations have a
responsibility to hold power to account
not amplify voices of power without
context and caution it's just insane
it's fully crazy and apparently there
were there a bunch of people from the
newer attempts were saying my sources
aren't even talking to me anymore
my sources won't give me information
anymore because of this op-ed sure sure
they won't
sure they won't sure the source is
leaking you information and
gonna go silent on you because they
didn't like Tom cotton by the way I am
amazed this is where they draw the line
the New York Times they've run op eds
from Vladimir Putin from Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad they've run op eds in
support of communism they've run op eds
from the Chinese government but Tom
cotton says maybe we should use the
military to put down rioting and looting
if nothing else if Isis and here's the
legal authority to do so and my god
you're endangering everyone
hey this is religious religious nonsense
religious nonsense my favorite religious
video actually of the of the week comes
courtesy of some account called digital
forests I guess this is a video from New
York so after some of the rioting and
looting there were some people who
apparently owned a building or work for
a building owner and they were trying to
clean graffiti off the side of a
building which is what you should do
because graffiti is illegal and bad and
ugly and terrible
graffiti is defacement of private
property so naturally a woke white woman
rolls up and she starts lecturing these
women who aren't cleaning off the
graffiti saying they are racist for
cleaning off the graffiti you shall
atone here's our new ridiculous standard
of the moment and I'm going to shame
shame shame shame
so Game of Thrones and forced these
people to walk naked through a crowd
while he tossed excrement that them
because they're cleaning graffiti off a
wall here is this video it's insane why
are you guys removing black life matters
graffiti
well why do you want that to come off
yes
but so you don't care about black lives
that
that's what this not enough to leave up
a message
brain not not a great way to use your
white privilege ladies not a great not a
great way to use your white privilege oh
go to hell
I mean seriously you're in favor of
racism if you're cleaning graffiti off a
federal building cuz I'm gonna private
building it's a federal building
insanity full-scale insanity but this is
the way it's gonna work now you know
Lego Lego the company asked stores to
stop advertising police and White House
sets Legos
they are Legos the Legos are not racist
did the Legos kill George Floyd did the
leg are the Legos brutalizing black
people what in the actual living hell
are you talking about what in the world
I'll say what I'm gonna do today I'm
gonna go buy some Legos on discount
because like if I get them cheaper for
my kids I will absolutely do it absolute
insanity but these are the these are the
rituals that are required now the person
who has gotten hit the hardest over the
last 24 hours is of course the New
Orleans Saints quarterback Drew Brees
he's a future hall-of-famer is a new
he's a Super Bowl winner
he said something super bad super duper
bad that requires octone Minj What did
he say that was so bad he said I don't
like when people kneel for the national
anthem the American flag which by the
way is like a 60/40 proposition in the
United States and before Trump it was
like an 8020 proposition the people were
not really very hot on the idea of
kneeling for the American flag or the
national anthem because those used to be
unifying symbols what he's about to say
is so utterly uncontroversial that it
should go without saying but nothing
goes without saying and in fact if you
do say this then your speech has now
become a form of violence and also if
you are silent you are violent and also
if you do anything we don't like you are
violent so here is Drew Brees saying a
none controversial thing and then being
forced to walk it back by the most woke
among us LeBron James had nothing to say
about you know the Chinese government
cracking down on the NBA over over one
GM in the NBA saying a bad thing about
China in Hong Kong and by the way the
bad thing was correct LeBron James comes
down on Drew Brees for this here's
here's what drew brees had to say I will
never agree with anybody disrespecting
the flag of the United States of America
or our country let me let me just tell
you what
I see or what I feel when the national
anthem is played and when I look at the
the flag of the United States I envision
my two grandfather's who fought for this
country during World War two one in the
army and one in the Marine Corps both
risking their lives to protect our
country and to try to make our country
in this world a better place so every
time I stand with my hand over my heart
looking at that flag and singing the
national anthem that's what I think
about okay and this was apparently
extremely bad very very terrible and bad
so bad that LeBron James went out there
and tweeted about it it was just it was
just awful LeBron James tweeted wow man
is it still surprising at this point
sure isn't you literally still don't
understand why cap was kneeling on one
knee
okay so let's be frank about this this
is LeBron James basically saying that
Colin Kaepernick was right so there are
some people who are saying okay Brees is
missing the point the kneeling right now
isn't the same as the kneeling that
Kaepernick was doing that's not true
okay we all know what that what the
kneeling is if he's been a symbol in
American public life for a while so
LeBron James tweets out about this and
he tweets out you still don't know what
Colin Kaepernick was doing well and then
he suggests that that it is very bad you
have to kneel he said he has absolutely
nothing to do with disrespect of the
flag of the United States and our
soldiers who keep our land free my
father-in-law was one of the men who
fought as well for this country I asked
him a question about it and thanked him
all the time for his commitment he never
found Kap peaceful protest offensive
because he and I both know what's right
is right and what's wrong is wrong god
bless you Richard Sherman also said he's
beyond lost about drew breeds beyond
lost guarantee you there were black men
fighting alongside your grandfather but
this doesn't seem to be about that that
uncomfortable conversation you're trying
to avoid by injecting military into a
conversation about brutality and
equality as part of the problem well
what if the Colin Kaepernick protest was
wrong what if all of these things are
true at the same time kneeling for the
national anthem is wrong kneeling for
the American flag is wrong police
brutality is bad and racism is bad and
the American flag does not represent
police brutality and racism right that's
the conflation that Colin Kaepernick
made and that's what drew brees was
objecting to but Drew Brees had to
apologize who's forced into a public
humiliation ritual yags this is how our
stupid country works now so drew Brees
was forced to apologize and he put out
a statement he said I would like to
apologize to my friends teammates the
city of New Orleans the black community
NFL community and anyone I hurt with my
comments yesterday and speaking with
some of you it breaks my heart to know
the pain I have caused he literally said
don't kneel for the American flag
apparently massive pain caused in an
attempt to talk about respect unity and
solidarity centered around the American
flag and the national anthem I made
comments that were insensitive and
completely missed the mark on the issues
we're facing right now
as a country and then he puts out a
bunch of statements about standing
against the systemic racial injustice
and police brutality and creation of
real policy change that will make a
difference condemning the years of
oppression that have taken place
throughout our black communities and
still exist today so now he is repeating
the the various slogans he's expected to
repeat in order so that he can be
expiated of his sin because that's the
way this works you say the American flag
is not bad and that the national anthem
is good and now you have to repeat all
of the slogans that you are sent by the
PR department over at the aural incensed
that's the way this is supposed to work
by the way the Broncos head coach was
forced to do the same thing Broncos head
coach said I think that there's minimal
he said he thinks that the NFL is a
league of meritocracy you earned what
you get you get what you earned he said
I don't see racism at all in the NFL I
don't see discrimination in the NFL by
the way huge majority of players in the
NFL are black and so he he then had to
put out a statement saying after
reflecting on my comments and listening
to players this morning I realized when
I said regarding racism and
discrimination in the NFL was wrong
while I have never personally
experienced those terrible things
firsthand during my 33 years in the NFL
I understand many players coaches and
staff have different perspectives I
should have been more clear and I am
sorry I look forward to listening to the
players both individually and
collectively there's a lot of work to be
done in the areas of diversity and
providing opportunities across the board
for I mean it's just unbelievable we're
just gonna force everybody to we're just
gonna force everybody to repeat these
same catechism the religion is quite
powerful it is quite powerful okay in a
second we're gonna get to the virtue
signaling by the by the people who are
attempting to demonstrate their bona
fide ease and the lack of clarity and
what exactly is being demanded so one of
the things I've been saying all along is
it seems like there should be some
agreement on some of the policy right we
should be able to agree that we need to
more clearly define for example
qualified immunity so yesterday on the
show as I was informed by people
correctly I misidentified the nature of
qualified immunity
does not mean you can't be prosecuted if
you are a police officer for doing that
thing it means that you're immune from
civil liability so long as you did
something that is quote-unquote within
the scope of agency the problem is that
the Supreme Court has failed to define
scope of agency so you have a bunch of
bad cases where people are doing stuff
that's clearly criminal and still cannot
be sued for that and by the way if the
individual can't be sued then the police
department ends up student attacks
parents up on the hook yeah I also
suggested the police unions are a
problem I agree I still agree with this
right I I'm not gonna back off the idea
that unions in general and public sector
are bad it is illegal for them to strike
that does not mean they have not struck
a struck in the past that they have
indeed committed strikes in the past
okay so but these are areas where there
should be some policy disagreement
between left and right and libertarians
and conservatives like Clarence Thomas
is very much in favor of changing the
qualified immunity doctrine for example
okay but here's the problem there's not
actual agreement among people on the
Left members of the religion about the
actual policies to be pursued there's
not actual agreement on this stuff
because the radicals don't want any of
that stuff the radicals don't care about
that stuff the radicals are openly
suggesting that we defund the police so
the black lives matter plans
apparently the black lives matter
movement will developed an armed branch
of peace officers to combat police
brutality and black communities during a
so-called war on police this is
according to an interview with The Daily
Mail where BLM New York Chapter chairman
Hawk Newsom describes how the group
plans to follow in those footsteps of
the Black Panther Party by matching a
fire with fire when necessary says we're
talking about defending our communities
you know what it's like to see a Taser
pointed at a seven-year-old you know
it's like see a 67 year old black woman
pepper sprayed and pushed to the ground
we're preparing and training to defend
our communities so he's now talking
about arming quote-unquote peace
officers open carrying firearms while
patrolling black communities in order to
deter police brutality now listen if you
are if you are abiding by the law and
open carrying do what you want to do
right I mean that's that is fully in
consonance with the law if you are
suggesting that when a police officer
comes to arrest somebody for a crime
that you need people who are going to
show up and stop that that's not that's
kind of a problem is it not
and then there's controversy on the left
over defunding the police so one of the
big slogans that is now gaining steam is
defund the police by the way if you've
enjoyed
last week in America if you've enjoyed
your free trial of major cities without
police I urge you to buy the
subscription Democrats are offering
because it seems like a really crappy
deal it seems like a veneer between
civilization and widespread rioting and
looting was like this thin and when you
remove the police it's gone
amazing okay so Brian Fallon was the
former press secretary for Hillary
Clinton 2016 dudes and mainstream
Democrat he tweeted out yesterday defund
the police defund the police yes get rid
of the police get rid of a genius idea
genius idea but there's disagreements on
the left about this proposition because
of course it's an idiotic idea so Eric
Garcetti called for cuts to police
funding in LA while the LAPD is wildly
understaffed as in like the New York
City Police Department is not
understaffed in terms of the populations
who police level or at least not to the
extent of LA LA is probably the most
understaffed major city in the country
in terms of just number of population -
number of police very very small
Department so Garcetti called for
serious cuts to police funding which
makes perfect sense in the middle of
rioting and looting in the middle of us
having to go into mandatory curfew each
night perfect times call for cuts to
police funding but the Congressional
Black Caucus chair actually opposes
defunding the police so there's
disagreements on the left about policy
as you will see this disagreements on
the left about policy ends up resolving
itself by avoiding policy discussions
entirely so we won't discuss policies
that could fix any of this instead what
we will discuss is broad statements
about American evil so here is here is
Karen bass representing Karen bass from
California she's chairman chairwoman of
the Congressional Black Caucus saying
that defund the police is a silly idea I
am not familiar with that demand of
black lives matter I work closely with
them and so I will consult them but if
you asked me my personal opinion no I
don't believe that we should be fun
police departments I think that we need
to come up with very significant
legislation now but I also think it's
time to have a conversation in our
country what is policing in America why
is it that we have two completely
different standards okay I mean first of
all we don't have two completely
different standards for how the police
treat people which is why this person's
going to go to jail if keith ellison
does his job
so what are some of the other policies
that are being put forward well Karen
bass also says that we're going to vote
for a committee to investigate the
possibility of slavery reparations if
this is a thing that's never going to
happen it's just not going to happen if
you believe that you can even identify
who ought to receive the slavery
reparations and who ought to pay the
slavery reparations 170 years later or
that by the way if you think that
cutting like a thirty or forty thousand
dollar check everybody who is a
descendant of a slave in the United
States is going to end he claim that
America is responsible for all
inequality you're wrong it's obviously
an under pitch atonic EC Coates admitted
as much he had a que he he wrote a long
piece for the Atlantic a couple of years
ago trying to revive the slavery
reparations today suggesting the case
for slavery reparations and he said well
we could try it but maybe it won't work
yeah well then what do you what are you
talking about here is Karen bass
suggesting a policy that's never going
to get passed obviously I've not had a
specific compass conversation with
speaker Pelosi but I've certainly talked
to other members of leadership and being
on you dish where that bill is I believe
that it will move I don't know what will
be in the package that the house passes
at this point a time I know the broad
strokes and we are looking at that but I
do believe that it will be voted on out
of the out of committee and hopefully
out of the house before the session
concludes okay so then there will be a
board that investigates slavery
reparations makes a bunch of vague
recommendations and then doesn't do
anything and then America will be
accused of being racist for not passing
slavery reparations and if there are
slavery reparations if there ever were
to happen then it will be deemed not
enough money to rectify the imbalances
of the last 200 years we all know where
this is going so the the broader black
lives matter sort of agenda is not any
specific policy preference because the
BLM agenda which includes defund the
police is not even popular with many on
the left so instead you sort of have
these people who are reverting to the
religious to the religious the religious
is the only thing that unifies this at
this point and that religion has certain
things that you are supposed to just
believe the core beliefs the core
beliefs core beliefs like America is is
America's original sin with slavery but
it wasn't just America's original sin
every bad thing that happens now is
attributable to America's original sin
so here is Barack Obama giving a widely
praised speech in the media because
everything Barack
as is widely praised in the media here
was Obama yesterday saying that Floyd's
death is related to America's original
sin of slavery how he makes that
connection is absolutely beyond me we
don't know the chavín is a racist we
know that he engaged in an act of police
brutality
we don't know the surrounding
circumstances of the arrest we don't
know what this has to do with slavery I
mean like really this is a pretty major
leap but it's the leap that is it's the
leap of faith that is required of you to
believe that the great malevolent god of
racism stands behind all events in the
United States here's Barack Obama
proselytizing what has happened over the
last several weeks is challenges and
structural problems here in the United
States have been thrown into high relief
they're the result of a long history of
slavery and Jim Crow and redlining and
institutionalized racism that too often
have been the plague this original sin
of our society okay that is the article
of faith the article of faith is that
everything bad that happens is a racist
thing and every and every racist thing
is due to America's inherent nature that
is the and and you are expected to
repeat this catechism because we can't
actually grant policy if we actually
talk about policy then maybe we could
have an intelligent conversation but
we're not gonna do that instead you're
just supposed to listen and believe and
then repeat it's listen believe repeat
that is the formula here and so we have
some people who have taken it upon
themselves to listen and believe in our
people by the way the other thing that
you're supposed to do is pretend that if
you say this catechism then it makes you
a victim in some ways so John boyega
who's one of the stars of the Star Wars
films he plays Finn he is not true did
you play polar Finn I can I can never I
make I mix them up he plays for that's
right you play yes Finn cuz it's FN
right because he's a member of the
stormtrooper brigade in any case he if
he plays Finn and he's fine he's good
actor he shows up at a black lives
matter protest in London and he declares
that he might not have a career after
the speech as though as though there is
a bevy of people in Hollywood who are
looking to blacklist him for saying the
most popular thing you could say in
Hollywood which is that America is bad
in racist here is John boyega yesterday
a nation that's up with individual
families are thriving there are healthy
that communicate that raise their
children in love have a better way of
becoming better human beings see and
that's what we need to create black men
it starts with you man from a heart
look I don't know if I'm gonna have a
career after this
[Laughter]
okay first of all everything that he
says there is not only uncontroversial
in like normal terms its uncontroversial
in every term when he says that if you
lead a thriving life at a level clay to
have better outcomes that's not that's
not remotely controversial he's not even
saying the controversial part of the
black lives matter sloganeering I mean
that's not even the controversial part
okay then you have people like the
Dutchess of Sussex so Meghan Markel is
now speaking out and I'm excited now
that she's speaking out so the Duchess I
needed to hear from her it was very
important that I hear from Meghan Markel
so Meghan Markel is now speaking out
because of course silence is violence
here is the Duchess of Sussex speaking
out about this issue as one of the she
is deemed to be one of the cased of
people who are allowed to speak and you
are supposed to listen and repeat
everything she says for the past couple
weeks I've been planning on saying a few
words to you for your graduation and as
we've all seen over the last week what
is happening in our country and in our
state and in our hometown of LA has been
absolutely devastating and I realized
the only wrong thing to say is to say
nothing
George Floyd's life mattered and Brianna
Taylor's life mattered and falando
Castillo's life mattered and Tamir
Rice's life mattered okay we agree about
all those things my favorite line there
though is the only wrong thing to say is
to say nothing I feel like that's not
true I feel like Drew Brees had a thing
and then that was the wrong thing to say
I feel like it turns out that you guys
have a very specific idea of what can be
said and what cannot be said under these
circumstances and so what you actually
mean by the wrong thing to say is
nothing is that if you say exactly what
I want you to say then we are very happy
with you prime my favorite celebrity
take of the last couple days - can coach
are trying to explain black lives matter
and completely botching it in the
process it's pretty pretty fun there's
Ashton Kutcher explaining the explaining
black lives matter - to all of you other
unwell quite people because Ashton is
woke so that means that he can lecture
you he's allowed when it comes to black
lives matter I think what folks that are
writing all lives matter need to
understand is that for some people
for some people black lives don't matter
at all so for us black lives matter
whoo-hoo one name two names like really
who is it that is such what what he
means by that is I'm not one of those
people I am a member of the initiated
I'm a member of the initiated for some
people who are these people of whom you
speak I mean even even the person you
hate most President Trump has made
repeated statements about how joyed
George Floyd's killer should be brought
to justice
right every like everyone everyone but
again that's part of the catechism
because every religion also has to have
people who are outside the religion so
you can say that those people are
heretics and wrong and those are the
Damned well we who are the initiative n'
okay meanwhile in other news the the
major controversy has broken out over
general james nana so you remember the
Secretary of Defense he left the Trump
administration a couple of years ago in
December 2018 he left over president
Trump's Syria policy that's when
President Trump randomly just made an
announcement that he's gonna withdraw
troops from Syria and ended up clearing
the way for Turkey to sort of invade
northern Syria and Madison I don't like
this and he left well now he's put out a
statement just ripping Trump up and down
so a couple of preliminaries here I'm
not gonna rip Jim's madis as a person
James mattis is an American Hero he is a
service person he has served in honor he
has done great things for the United
States I think that his characterization
of a lot of this stuff is just dead
wrong I think a lot of his
characterization here to be completely
fair I think it's just dead wrong and
this is coming from somebody who's kind
of a maddest fan so here's what mattis
wrote he said I've watched this week's
unfolding events angry and appalled the
words equal justice under law are carved
in the pediment of the United States
Supreme Court this is precisely what
protesters are rightly demanding it is a
wholesome and unifying demand one that
all of us should be able to get behind
so if that's all that the protesters
were demanding I'd be it behind it like
full score obviously that's not all that
they are demanding even if even if
that's most of what they're demanding
I've said protesting for that again for
the two millionth time I've said
protesting in favor of equal protection
of the laws totally on board
do it right spend
entire first 20 minutes of this
particular episode talking about the
necessity for properly charging a person
so he goes to jail for equal justice
under law okay but Madison is miss
reading the room here he says we must
not be distracted by the small number of
lawbreakers distracted by the small
number of lawbreakers um dude dude dude
45 million Americans were confined to
quarters at 6 o'clock p.m. across the
United States a couple of nights ago we
have seen at this point we're
approaching double-digit deaths from
these riots we've seen billions of
dollars in property damage we have seen
people lose their life savings we have
seen the complete destruction of
American freedoms on America's streets
that's not a small number of looters you
don't shut down a county in LA of 10
million people at 6 p.m. every night for
a week for a small number of looters
that ain't this ok then he says the
protests are defined by tens of
thousands of people of conscience or
insisting we live up to our values our
values as people and our values as a
nation we must reject and hold
accountable those in office would make a
mockery of our Constitution ok who are
these evil evil horrible people then he
goes straight at Trump he says Donald
Trump is the first president in my
lifetime who does not try to unite the
American people does not even pretend to
try instead he tries to divide us ok you
can find Donald Trump divisive you can
but to pretend the divisive nough sand
American politics started with Donald
Trump is just to be absolutely myopic
and politically ignorant Barack Obama
was an incredibly divisive president go
back and look at the polling data when
Barack Obama took office most Americans
were quite hopeful about race relations
by the time he left office most
Americans were not hopeful about race
relations Barack Obama spent years
saying the Cambridge police acted
stupidly when they did not suggesting
that you don't bring a knife to a
gunfight with regards his political
enemies suggesting the tea partiers were
terrorists suggesting that Fox News was
a propaganda outlet the President of the
United States Barack Obama spent years
suggesting that that every black person
is in the same sort of danger as Trayvon
Martin suggesting that the rioters in
Ferguson and looters in Ferguson had
justification for the rioting and
looting because people don't make things
up even though the case regarding
Michael Brown was indeed made up the
President of the United States deployed
his vice presidents who say that Mitt
Romney wanted to put y'all back in
Chains he suggested that he had a
typical white grandmother the
grandmother raised him by the way was a
typical white person who was subtly
racist Barack Obama was a very very
divisive president
I know that we're all supposed to
pretend that the world started revolving
the Milou and the Donald Trump became
president but it's not true it's just
not it's not accurate so mattis's we are
witnessing the consequences of three
years of this deliberate effort okay I
have a question what was Ferguson in
Baltimore about that happened under
Obama was that also because if Trump he
says we are witnessing the consequences
of three years without mature leadership
we can unite without him drawing on the
strengths inherent in our civil society
well we didn't when Obama was president
so I'm looking for it so this will not
be easy as the past few days have shown
but we owe it to our fellow citizens to
pass generations that bled to defend our
promise to our children and then he says
instructions given by military
departments to our troops before the
Normandy invasion reminded soldiers that
the Nazi slogan for destroying us was
divide and conquer our American answer
is in Union there is strength we must
summon that unity to surmount this
crisis confident that we are better than
our politics okay so I'm wondering who
is destroying the Constitution when you
literally have complete lawlessness
overrunning America cities and the
president invoking a constitutional
insurrection act and not even using it
right saying he might use it as far as
the idea that divide and conquer was
then was the Nazi slogan while America
was in Union there is strength I'm
wondering who exactly feels more unified
these days do you feel a lot more
unified if that is a trump or is it
possible these these rifts have been
emerging for decades that the academia
the academic mentality of critical
theory and critical race studies that
suggests that we are all but members of
our race is racial reductionism where
Joe Biden tells you you're not actually
black if you don't vote for Joe Biden
maybe this divisive in this predates
Donald Trump so well I have a lot of
respect for general mattis as a person I
think that this statement is wildly
off-base unfortunately it's really not
good for Trump right it's very very bad
for President Trump to have his former
Secretary of Defense ripping him from
then comes back at him and then this
follows hard on a couple other major
defense officials who are coming after
Trump as well so defense secretary Mark
Esper said that he was aware on Monday
night of his plan to visit the
Washington church again I thought it was
a dumb plan this plan to go into a photo
op in front of the church at least if
you're gonna do it wait until curfew to
clear the crowd right they didn't wait
till curfew to clear the crowd there's a
peaceful protest in Lafayette Park by
most available metrics there are some
people who are suggesting that that
bottles were being thrown at the cops if
that's true that's a different story we
haven't seen the tape of that from the
tape that looks most like people are
standing there and then the cops just
start clearing them or the Secret
Service starts clearing them and then
the
clear the area so Trump can walk out
hold up the Bible and go back in very
dumb photo-op but the the Defense
Secretary says he got roped into it
which is always a great look he says he
wasn't aware of the photo-op here is the
the Defense Secretary creating some
daylight between himself and Trump on
this I did know that we were going to
the church I was not aware of a photo op
was happening of course the president
drags a large press pool along with him
to look I do everything I can to try
State a political and to try and stay
out of situations that may appear
political and sometimes I'm successful
doing that and and sometimes I'm not a
successful but my aim is to keep the
department out of politics to stay
apolitical and that's what I continue to
try and do as well as my leaders here in
the department okay meanwhile the army
general mark Milley who's chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff was also
dragged along that particular photo-op
turns out that this is mmm one of the
more major political own goals of modern
politics he sent a open letter an
unclassified open letter to the chief of
staff of the Army commands and
Commandant of the Marine Corps Chief of
Naval Operations chief staff of the Air
Force chief of the National Guard
comments on to the Coast Guard chief of
Space Operations and commanders of the
combatant commands and his message was
follow the Constitution right is it
which is should be fairly obvious but
the implication is fairly obvious as
well so mark Milley sends out this
letter saying every member of the US
military swears an oath to support and
defend the Constitution and the values
embedded within it this documented this
document is founded on the essential
principle that all men and women are
born free and equal and should be
treated with respect and dignity
it also gives Americans the rights of
freedom of speech and peaceful assembly
we in uniform remain committed to our
national values and principles embedded
in the Constitution during the current
crisis the National Guard is operating
under the authority of state governors
to protect lives and property preserve
peace and ensure public safety as
members of the joint force comprised of
all races colors and creeds you embody
the ideals of our Constitution please
remind all of our troops and leaders we
will uphold the values of our nation and
then he hand wrote on this piece of
paper we are we are we all committed our
lives the idea that is America we will
stay true to that oath and the American
people okay so the implication is pretty
hard not to read into that he's only
sending a letter that restates the
obvious because he's attempting to chide
Trump pretty good pretty clearly right
so dad none of that is particularly good
for president Trump from being at war
with
chief of staff of the the Joint Chiefs
him being at worth don't defense
secretary him being orthis former
defense secretary like his whole goal
here was to look tough his whole goal
here was to look like he was a
law-and-order guy and having your
defense establishment kind of going at
you is not a good look
forget about the fact that that I think
that that madis is wrong in his in his
particular take on politics a known goal
is a known goal and you have to
acknowledge a known goal when it happens
there's a reason right now that the
polls are not looking good for president
Trump president Trump needs to rein it
in he needs to rein in his behavior he
needs to ensure that he runs a much more
disciplined campaign because right now
things are quite ugly for the president
in the polling data and before you
discount all the polls recognize that
the polls at this point in time did not
even have Barack Obama up eight on Mitt
Romney in 2012 and right now the average
polling data and at no point was Hillary
up eight uh none Donald Trump at no
point right now Joe Biden is in the
RealClearPolitics polling average up
eight points and Trump is trailing in
virtually every battleground state
according to Fox News polling according
to the Fox News polling Trump is now
trailing in in Arizona he's trailing in
Ohio he's trailing in Wisconsin pulls
our deadlock in Texas these are the
disastrous numbers for the president
he's got to turn this around some way
and he must do it quickly it's a bad
situation for for him politically at the
very least already we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise we
will see you here tomorrow also I have
an all-access tonight so make sure to
check that out go go subscribe and I'll
answer all your questions in a Q&A in
which I wear a t-shirt that's always our
major pitch and while you're at it go
pick up a copy of my new book how to
destroy America in three easy steps come
to actual I 21st it is about all of the
things all of the things I seriously
could not be more timely this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2025 you know the Matt Walsh oh
it's not just another show about about
politics I think there are enough of
those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else so my main
focus is our life family faith those are
fundamental and that's what this show is
about I hope you'll give it a listen
you